today we're going to try and revive this
very old machine which I've been told is
eight years old running XP it's running
a Core 2 Duo which is quite impressive
for its age and the screen is lovely but
it is unfortunately very slow so if I go
here and I open up my computer waiting
waiting waiting and there it's open
ok so that was substantially longer than
we would expect from a modern day
machine but besides that nothing
scratched while I've been using it it's
fairly stable nice butt support for XP
is being cut off soon there's a large
portion of the windows community at the
moment who are reluctant to move forward
to Windows 7 or Windows 8 now especially
and it can be quite expensive to operate
an operating system you don't want in
the first place so the best alternative
for many people is to try and Linux miss
sam'l is like a star in a computer noise
so if you look at some of the popular
systems nowadays like for example the
armed Chromebook by Samsung the series 8
I think it is that was best seller on
Amazon over Christmas in terms of size
and portability and power consumption
modern systems such as series 8 are
better but performance wise they're not
too removed from this and the reason
that they are able to be as quick and
snappy as they are is with the minimized
operating system disorder so in the case
of the Samsung Chromebook its Chrome OS
and Chrome OS is very stripped down if
you want electrocution in this case Gen
2 and it's really quick and very capable
and this is a similar principle talk
we're doing here we're taking a much
lighter fresh operating system and this
will be like a new machine aside from
the way the power consumption in the
bathroom this is the cade of it so it's
gotta be plugged into the AC all the
time and the AC speaking of which is
held together with a Verve silicon phone
their usage wise it will be much fresher
much friend down and will be completed
and experience what it was before the
version movement we're using is 0.04 so
that's the version released in April of
2012 and that was the last long-term
support version so they released a new
version the new version Alisa's the
cutting-edge one but then every now and
then they released a long-term support
version and this is a version that
they've basically got to a stage where
they think this is perfectly stable this
is rock-solid this is suitable for use
by industry and people who need this
operating system to be stable for years
to come
so like this machine is still reliable
using XP now machines will be using
Ubuntu 12.04 probably for decades yeah
there'll be new long-term support
versions before then but the idea is
that they won't have to upgrade they can
stick the system for a long time the
process we're going to go through
in brief is downloading operating system
in this case have been to twelve point
oh four right a tween USB stick and then
your computer can boot from it and you
can get your printer straight away so if
I start unetbootin essentially it's made
for installing Linux distributions onto
Windows machines so as you can see I've
got this list here I'll put the next
distribution so you can choose to
download if you did just want to
download on fresh you could just
download unetbootin without going to any
have a website and choose which one you
wanted but we've got no internet
connection right now but we've already
downloaded ours so we're gonna ignore
this step entirely so I'm going to find
the disk image which is on the desktop
which could take me a while your
networking is pretty simple you set it
off you don't do anything so we are now
extracting and copying the files it's
not cool about this is that when this is
done this USB stick will be live
bootable you can plug this USB stick
into a computer set the computer to boot
from it and you'll have a delinked
operating system that you can use
straight away from the USB stick without
installing it you can boot into it you
can use its programs you can even save
files and they'll get written to the USB
stick but essentially means that you
have your own operating system on the go
but 1198 it's if it's got stuck worrying
so you're not going to take them quite a
long time we've been stuck on a 11 out
of 198 files for a while now so we
fought we pop in the task manager see
what's going on so this shows what the
CPU has been doing over time so we've
got the two cores here and then over
here we've got kind of a live CPU usage
graph this shows us how much of the
processor it's being used at the given
time we're doing a simple extraction
here it's current using upwards of sixty
percent of the processors to snip down a
bit but it was using about 65 which is
quite an insane amount for a dual-core
processor but it appears to have gotten
unstuck now and it's churning along
nicely unetbootin is just finished and
so we've got insulation complete and we
can now reboot so now your net Bouton's
done this USB stick it's a fully capable
and then it's operating system we can't
boot from it I'm now rebooting the
Machine and then I'll go into the BIOS
and change the boot order and say
instead of booting from the hard drives
of the Machine it boot straights in USB
stick when you stop the machine you get
a little screen that says the
manufacturer's name so I press f2 off a
boot and are now in the boot menu just
allows us to select the desired boot
device so 1000 hard drive is what you
normally boots from so we're going to
choose the USB storage device this is
now going through to boot this flashing
at the moment it's probably looking for
a operating system on a USB storage
device
so hopefully the work if this has worked
in a minute we should see the grub menu
Oh No shouldn't take that long
I saw the hot rod scanning weirdly
enough $1 sufficient are you doing with
it so a DVD you've got blade you're on a
nice classic film unfortunately no good
for Linux distribution that'd be
fantastic so that didn't seem to work we
got stuck in the flashing white line of
doom for absolute the edges so I'm going
to check that the distribution is
written properly um much newer Dell
so let's check the file system ok that
looks rested complete and that looks
like things that it looks like
unetbootin it's done its job properly
and I should be working so what I'm
going to do instead is I'm going to
check whether it's the USB stick or
whether it's that machine and quickly
try booting into it on here we go for
the same process on here already missed
the button there yes I have what do mr.
bumble it was quick as the problem of
our laptops of SSDs is increasingly hard
to actually get into the boot menu you
have to have incredibly fast eyes and
fingers to give another who got you a
trick pony which is cool ok some in the
B options so I'm going to boot from our
USB storage device
thanks XP ah operators not found okay so
our USB stick isn't working so we will
try writing again and so we're gonna
just using a key model on utility called
D D which will let us extract the I
socialist disk and hopefully have some
success I don't know the commands of my
head so I got a copy peasants in this
page I've just check to see if it's
working on this machine so no no dictum
it went free to be fine
boot up into a bin T so now we're gonna
have the moment of truth and try it on
the patient stickers plugged in I don't
have to rush press f12 really quickly on
this one all right okay that's good for
got the first screen so weirdly enough
this version pops up of a blanket
powerful scream of just a disability
accessibility option symbol and then
goes through to nothing which is build
so we're now waiting to load the
operating system okay so a is now
loading so soft first taste of adventure
on this machine and so we can notify
than 2000 about making any change to the
computer it won't change the existing
operating system it won't touch a thing
just the USB stick and RAM or
alternatively we can install it but do
straight away so let's try but - first
of all and it's pre - it compared to a
next figure ready look how quick that
stuff is opening I mean I wonder if we
could even watch Bladerunner as well as
it being free in terms of cost this is
free in terms of safety assessment
efforts so if you want to try and Linux
if you go for the process we've done
today and when you put on USB stick and
you try like this it won't impact your
existing system if you go into the boot
menu I'm starting up you don't even
permanently change anything you just
temporarily ask to boot from USB and
then when you take out restart you're
good so you can try out have a go see if
it's for you if you want to finish you
just shots now take the stick out and
then you're back to your normal Window
System or Mac well wait this is your
money and without damaging anything and
then once you're ready you can back up
install it run and paste they go Firefox
tied up we get a small period of loading
a flashing but then it's up its going on
we've got no internet connection right
now but it loaded proof quickly we do
the same for libera office so the
openoffice and libreoffice suite quite
notorious for being reasonably slow but
that's pretty chirpy there we go we're
into an office application
some drawbacks here what about using
files from LibreOffice on somewhere else
there yeah so
liber off it so because this is all free
and all doing relatively well it's so
successful
there are some kind of
passive-aggressive attempts to put a
stop to it so especially with Libre
Office you find that it has trouble
rendering the newer Microsoft Office
formats so if you're dealing with
formats from office 2013 or anything
docx
sometimes the fancier formatting options
don't come up perfectly and it does
mangled documents sometimes but for the
basics it works perfectly and if you
save to an older form it's kind of
saving to work formats of people with
word can open it and is largely slave to
an old format it works really well
that's not an unbearable waiting time
then I'm fit this would be a pretty nice
isn't used so with that should we go
straight to installing it so the install
menu is really straightforward nothing
complicated it asked you to check some
different things
I just finished so this 8 year old
system was on XP was taking ages to
heart was taking ages 12 new programs
we've written a two legs retribution to
this USB stick confidence dual process
we've tried out first we then installed
it we deleted XP offset and we've booted
it up and it's still a couple of drivers
free to play youtube videos ass or thing
sound is working out the box and
networking is working out the box it's
much quicker everything is working
perfectly it's a demonstrate well end on
a muscle
[Music]
you
if you think a command-line utility
called DD which will let us extract the
ISO so the install menu is really
straightforward nothing complicated it
actually to check some different things